hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his essay on truth and lying in an
extra moral sense one of the things that
Nietzsche is going to talk about towards
the middle part and the end that I think
a lot of people find confusing is
idealism and its contrast or relation to
natural law and science and I think that
this notion of natural law that's a
little hazy for it for a lot of people
but the notion of science is what
scientists do is what we learn in
science classes
that I think is fairly straightforward
and natural law was a way that you know
a lot of people in in Nietzsche's time
we're conceptualizing what it is that
that science does science discovers the
natural laws of things it's a science is
not just about discovering facts or you
know creating some sort of hypothesis
and then you know confirming it in in
terms of a theory or any of that sort of
stuff that we teach particularly - you
know kids in school science is really
about discovering the natural laws the
regularities that lie behind all of the
things that we might call the
appearances or the empirical realities
that we're encountering science reveals
to us the insides of the universe you
could say the guts and no so do we
typically think of it these days
in terms of what can be expressed
through through mathematics so we look
today and even in an in nature's time I
would say as physics a mathematize
physics is really being sort of the
paradigm and then we have you know
chemistry biology all these other
sciences what is idealism in this
discussion then what does nietzsche mean
does he mean sort of a optimism about
things no it's not that meaning does he
have in mind a kind of fuzzy headedness
that's different than you know concerned
with empirical reality no not exactly
what he has in mind is
a philosophical idealism that was often
contrasted against a scientific or what
we might call positive attitude and why
is he bringing this up at this point why
is he telling us that you know there
should be a kind of distrust of this he
says you know any person familiar with
such meditations has felt a dis deep
distrust for that sort of idealism and
then he connects us with the eternal
laws as often as he is clearly convinced
himself with the eternal coherence
omnipresence and infallibility of the
laws of nature so he's really presenting
it almost like a dilemma look either you
can have idealism whatever that's gonna
mean here or you can have the laws of
nature understood as eternal immutable
omnipresent now notice that he's using
divine attribute language here the
language that people used to attribute
to God in part because Nietzsche does
think and this is a somewhat separate
topic that the man of science the the
character you know of the modern era is
really a theologian in disguise
by contrast the idealism that
Nietzsche's talking about here is in a
certain respect you might say a more if
we want to be a little facetious here
honest approach to the relationship
between the subject the human being the
person who's trying to know things and
the object the world of things that
they're getting to know so let's
backtrack a little bit in the text
Nietzsche tells us that there really is
no standard no criterion for right
perception that is of empirical reality
of objects we've seen that earlier in
the piece he's talked about the fact
that you know even perception itself
involves a kind of metaphorical transfer
concept formation language all involve
this and then we forget about that we
think that there's regularities that are
really socially
acted regularities that we don't treat
as such and eventually come to take for
granted so he says that the insect or
the bird perceives a completely
different world than the human being
does and the question which of these two
world perceptions is more right which is
grasping the object is a completely
senseless one we don't have a standard
for that he says basically the right
perception that would mean the adequate
expression of an object in the subject
and they says this seems to me to be a
self contradictory absurdity why because
between the at two absolutely different
spheres such as subject and object
Nietzsche says there can only be an
aesthetic relation a relation of
perception a relation that involves art
that involves metaphor that involves you
might say an effective response not the
cold hard replicable facts of science
right those are really he's saying more
assumptions than anything else and so he
talked here about the need for some sort
of middle sphere he says I mean we have
a sort of elusive transference going on
here translation in a completely foreign
medium for this for a freely fictional
fictionalizing and freely inventive
middle sphere and middle faculty is
necessary so one way of understanding
this which Nietzsche is proposing is
that we do in fact engage in a kind of
metaphorical and he's even going to use
the word a little bit later intuitive
approach to this another way is that of
philosophical idealism which says that
we do in fact in some sense construct
the universe of objects out there we are
projecting the order the regularity the
in fact meaning onto
being that we find and this is something
that you can get out of cod a conscient
idealism this is something also that you
can get in a different way out of Hegel
or out of Schopenhauer right so there's
an idealist tradition which includes
many different viewpoints on this Fichte
as well he may have in mind here and the
idea is that what we find in the object
is what we inject into the object so he
goes on and he says it's not true that
the essence of things appears in the
empirical world and he goes on and says
the the relation of a nerve stimulus to
produce picture is not a necessary one
when the same image has been produced
millions of times and has been passed on
ultimately appearing to all mankind as a
result of the same occasion in the end
it has the same significance as if it
were the only necessary image and so
what we've got here he likens it also to
a dream if we have the same dream over
and over and over and over again we
forget that it's a dream we forget that
we are the subject who is in effect
creating the meaning creating the
regularity creating the truth there in
the side of the object which is not just
an object but an entire world a world
that we can't empirically grasp as a
totality anyway so he says coming back
to this key point when we think about
this we should feel a kind of mistrust
for that kind of idealism what's going
to allow us to feel that mistrust when
we think instead of this idealism being
the case that we have these laws of
nature that we can rely upon when we
view these as coherent omnipresent
infallible so he says he drew the
conclusion everything here as far as we
can penetrate to the you talks about the
telesco
OPIC world which means you know and
here's a reference to cut you know the
starry skies above then we have the
microscopic world we can go infinitely
large we can go infinitely small and
we're always going to find these same
laws of nature that's that's the way in
which this mindset the scientific
mindset approaches matters we'll always
find these laws of nature they're always
going to be the same so he says we find
that we find you know these things
endlessly securely regularly without
gaps science will have to dig
successfully in these shafts forever
everything it finds will coincide and
not contradict itself science will just
keep growing and growing and growing and
adding more and more data and
understanding these laws of nature more
and more fully applying them to
different ranges of phenomena you know
unpacking things is that really what
happens that's something we should
consider does science really work in the
way that science tells itself or
portrays itself to the populous as
working and the answer is no but we go
on and he says how little and he's being
ironic here this resembles a product of
fantasy for if it were that it would
surely betray it's a loser enos and
unreality at this point then he says
well let's see if that is the case
against this reasoning we can say this
and he gives you an argument here about
you know how perception could be
different and how it could change and
what that would mean for us and that no
one would talk about regularity of
nature but they would grasp it as a
highly subjective formation they would
grasp but the way the idealists were
doing now what do we actually find when
we think about what science is telling
us about the object when I went looking
at this entire world that is supposed to
be out there not merely empirical but
we're grasping it in its nature in its
essence he says do we ever really grasp
the essences of things what is a law of
nature do we know a law of nature he
says no it's not known as such but only
in its effects we're treating it as a
kind of cause according to old schemas
of causality but we don't actually know
the cause we know the effects again it
could be pointed out here Nietzsche is
making a analogy without telling us as
such between what the person of science
does and the theologians who also argued
about God based on effects and said we
cannot know that ultimate cause in
itself only through its relations and
Nietzsche says here we know the laws of
nature through their relations all these
relations refer back only to one another
and are absolutely incomprehensible to
us in their essence we add to them
things like space-time what do we have
their succession in numbers and
Nietzsche says did you ever stop to
think just how how strange it is that we
are able to mathematize things so well
and he's hinting here that science and
the laws of nature these two
interdependent we could call them
activity and concepts a really a
disguised form of idealism he goes on
and he tells us everything marvelous we
admire in the laws of nature and
promotes our explanation could mislead
us into distrusting idealism consists in
exclusively of the mathematical
stringency and inviolability of space
and time perceptions but we produce
these out of ourselves which is exactly
what the idealists are saying so in our
distrust of idealism we fall into
another kind of idealism a pneumo
of idealism that we call non idealism
positivism scientific attitudes all all
these sorts of wonderful things and we
tell our self a false story so he says
we produce these out of ourselves with
the same necessity as a spider spins its
web if we're not compelled to grasp all
things only under these forms then it is
not surprising that in all four things
we really grasp only these forms for
they all must carry the laws of number
themselves
and number is the very thing that's most
astonishing about things and he says
isn't it funny how we find this
regularity in the objects in the Stars
and in the things that we're observing
and then we also find it in our minds we
said oh wonderful we have an ADD
equation of mind and reality that's
because we put it there in the first
place according to Nietzsche so what
does this mean then for science and the
laws of nature does it mean that it's we
throw it all away and it's no good no no
he's not saying that but it certainly
means that the picture of what's going
on in science and with these laws of
nature is quite different than what
science portrays to itself about its own
activity or rather we should say what
the person of science whether it be the
practicing scientist the apostle of
science out there you know doing talk
shows and and videos and and podcasts
and all that sort of stuff you know as a
medium what it is that there is telling
themselves and telling everybody else
it's not really a true story and it
really conceals its own form of idealism
you